From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life .
来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，这是《美国生活》。
Good morning, everyone. I feel like a school teacher. Good morning, teacher. It's very overwhelming to see such a great turnout this morning. I'm just so excited because I know it was very hard to get out of bed on this very, very cold New England morning. I've just been given the overwhelming task of introducing this amazing man. And I'm totally speechless right now. And I am just extremely excited.
大家早上好。我感觉自己像个老师。老师好。今天早上能有这么多人参加，我感到非常震撼。我真的很兴奋，因为我知道在这个非常、非常寒冷的新英格兰早晨起床是很困难的。我刚刚被赋予了一个艰巨的任务，就是介绍这位了不起的人。我现在完全说不出话来，但我感到无比兴奋。
[MUSIC - "IT STARTED ALL OVER AGAIN" BY FRANK SINATRA]
[音乐 - 弗兰克·辛纳屈演唱的《IT STARTED ALL OVER AGAIN》]
All of our stories today, brought to you from New Hampshire, where it has started again. Voters looking to fall for a candidate-- candidates, according to voters.
今天我们的所有故事都来自新罕布什尔州，一切又重新开始了。选民们希望能爱上一位候选人——根据选民的说法，是候选人们。
I'm very happy to be here this morning. This is the 70-something town hall meeting I've had in the state of New Hampshire. I had a guy come the other day, just before Christmas. He said, Senator McCain, this is the fifth town hall meeting you've had that I've attended. And I said, that's ample testimony to my inability to close the deal. Right.
我很高兴今天早上能来到这里。这是我在新罕布什尔州举办的第七十多场市民大会了。前几天圣诞节前，有个人来找我。他说，麦凯恩参议员，这是我参加的第五场您的市民大会。我说，这充分证明了我没能搞定这件事。对吧。
I want to talk about just a couple of issues of the day with you, because the thing I know about the people of New Hampshire,  they're not particularly interested in long speeches. In fact, they're not even interested in short speeches. They're interested in making comments, asking questions, and an occasional insult.
我想和你们谈谈当天的几个问题，因为我了解新罕布什尔州的人民，他们对长篇大论并不感兴趣。事实上，他们对短篇演讲也不感兴趣。他们感兴趣的是发表评论、提出问题，偶尔还会讽刺一下。
Today on our program, people looking for something to believe in, and many of them finding it, and what they know about the candidates that you don't know. Take, for example, Kahari Mosley and Garcia Suzinko. Three days into the beginning of the new millennium, they left home to do something they had never done before. They hopped on a bus in Pennsylvania and headed up to New Hampshire to volunteer for a presidential campaign. Kahari had never been to New England before. He looked out the bus window, he says, and saw trees all close together, boxy houses 100 years old.
今天我们的节目关注的是那些寻找信仰的人，他们中的许多人找到了信仰，以及他们了解到的关于候选人而你所不知道的事情。以卡哈里·莫斯利和加西亚·苏辛科为例。新千年开始后的第三天，他们离开家去做他们以前从未做过的事情。他们跳上一辆去往宾夕法尼亚州的公共汽车，前往新罕布什尔州为一场总统竞选做志愿者。卡哈里以前从未去过新英格兰。他说，他看着窗外，看到了紧挨在一起的树木，还有一百年历史的方形房子。
I was blown away. Because I was tapping him on the bus. We were about 10 minutes from Manchester. I'm tapping him on the bus like, yo, man. I started getting scared, because-- I mean there's country in Pennsylvania, but it's a different type of country. It's more kind of like NASCAR, WWF-type country. I mean, this is like American Gothic, like scary movie country.
我惊呆了。因为我在车上一直拍他。我们离曼彻斯特大约还有10分钟的路程。我在车上拍他，像是说，嘿，伙计。我开始感到害怕，因为——我的意思是宾夕法尼亚州也有乡村，但那是一种不同的乡村。更像是纳斯卡赛车或职业摔角那样的乡村。我的意思是，这简直像《美国哥特式》，就像恐怖电影里的乡村。
In rural New Hampshire, wherever Kahari and Garcia went, they could pretty much count on being the only African-Americans for miles. Knocking on doors for their candidate, they found a surprising number of people who wanted to tell them how great Colin Powell is. They tried to steer the conversation toward their candidate, Bill Bradley. They also did lit drops, put together canvassing kits, painted signs for a Bradley event down in Boston.
在新罕布什尔州的农村，无论卡哈里和加西亚走到哪里，他们几乎可以肯定自己是方圆几英里内唯一的非裔美国人。在为他们的候选人敲门拜票时，他们发现有相当多的人想告诉他们科林·鲍威尔有多么伟大。他们试图将谈话引向他们的候选人比尔·布拉德利。他们还分发传单，准备拉票工具包，为布拉德利在波士顿的一次活动绘制标语。
Like since he was a basketball player, like Boston Celtics Fans for Bradley. Like, go Bradley, you held Havlicek. Then we came up with the one, like welcome to a new Bill-ennium. Because like Will Smith had the Will-ennium, then I was like, flip it-- like, the Bill-ennium. You know what I mean?
就像因为他是篮球运动员，比如“波士顿凯尔特人球迷支持布拉德利”。比如，加油布拉德利，你防住了哈夫利切克。然后我们想出了一个口号，比如“欢迎来到新的布拉德利时代”。因为威尔·史密斯有“威尔时代”，然后我就想，反过来——比如，“布拉德利时代”。你知道我什么意思吗？
And what motivated these two college students to hop on a bus at their own expense and head north to work for free? It was one television appearance. One of those Sunday morning talk shows where, as Kahari remembers it, Bill Bradley said the two biggest social problems facing America are racism and materialism. Materialism. Kahari could not believe it. It was like running against the very idea of America.
是什么促使这两名大学生自费跳上一辆巴士，北上免费工作？是一次电视露面。那是星期天的早间访谈节目之一，正如卡哈里所记得的那样，比尔·布拉德利说美国面临的两个最大的社会问题是种族主义和唯物主义。唯物主义。卡哈里简直不敢相信。这就像是在与美国的根本理念背道而驰。
That's really one of the main things that's wrong with America on a day to day basis. I grew up in a low-income community. When you're impoverished and your life is defined by material things and you don't have it, you have a lack of self esteem. I grew up, I went to middle school, high school. If you have a certain pair of sneakers, people made fun of you. And that affects how you-- I know kids that didn't want to go to school. They didn't graduate from high school because they didn't have the right pair of sneakers on or the right jeans.
这确实是美国日常生活中存在的主要问题之一。我在低收入社区长大。当你贫困且生活被物质所定义，而你又没有这些东西时，你就会缺乏自尊。我成长过程中，读了初中、高中。如果你穿的运动鞋不对，人们就会嘲笑你。这会影响你的生活——我知道有些孩子不想上学。他们没有高中毕业，就是因为他们没有穿对运动鞋或牛仔裤。
I used to make fun of people. I'm guilty of it. You know what I mean? And knowing that, for someone to address that-- and I just saw it. And I was like, yo, I cannot believe he just said this on TV. And I remember, I started telling people. I was like, yo, man, this dude, look, this is what he said. I kept telling everybody I know what he said. And they're like, I can't believe he said that. He's never going to win. He's never going to win. And I was like, he's not going to win unless people support him.
我过去也嘲笑过别人。我对此感到内疚。你明白我的意思吗？知道有人能正视这一点——我当时看到了。我就想，嘿，我简直不敢相信他在电视上说了这些。我记得，我开始告诉别人。我说，伙计，这家伙，你看，这是他说的。我不断告诉每一个我认识的人他说了什么。他们说，我不敢相信他这么说了。他永远不会赢。他永远不会赢。我就说，如果人们不支持他，他当然不会赢。
And so he bought his bus ticket for Manchester. Today on our program, the politicians are looking for a way to connect with voters. The voters want candidates who inspire them. So how come so few of us are like Kahari? How come so few of us have a candidate we love? Today, we bring you stories that explain how come and stories of voters who have found inspiration.
于是他买了去曼彻斯特的巴士票。今天在我们的节目中，政客们正在寻找与选民建立联系的方式。选民们想要能激励他们的候选人。那么为什么像卡哈里这样的人这么少呢？为什么我们中很少有人拥有一个我们热爱的候选人？今天，我们带给你们的故事解释了原因，以及那些已经找到灵感的选民的故事。
Act One of today's show, Eliminate the Middleman. Sarah Vowell visits a high school class in Concord that decided to take on the national press. Act Two, The Mask Behind the Mask, in which an intrepid reporter tries to get beyond the sound bites with Governor George W. Bush and succeeds-- as well as anyone, anyway. Act Three, Pay No Attention to the Candidate Behind the Mosh Pit, in which we answer the question what is a presidential campaign good for anyway? Stay with us.
今天节目的第一部分，“消除中间人”。萨拉·沃威尔走访了康科德的一所高中班级，该班决定挑战全国性媒体。第二部分，“面具背后的面具”，一位勇敢的记者试图超越乔治·W·布什州长的音讯片段，并成功了——至少像任何人一样成功。第三部分，“别注意人潮背后的候选人”，我们将回答总统竞选到底有什么用这个问题。请继续收听。
Act One. Eliminate the Middleman. Here in America, here is how we interact with our political candidates. We dispatch middlemen to the scene. They tell us what the candidates say, they research the candidates' backgrounds, and they tell us what they think is most important. These middlemen, of course, are journalists. Sarah Vowell has this fable about the difference between the way the middlemen see the world and the way non-journalists see it.
第一部分。消除中间人。在美国，我们与政治候选人的互动方式是这样的。我们派遣中间人前往现场。他们告诉我们候选人说了什么，他们调查候选人的背景，并告诉我们他们认为最重要的事情。这些中间人当然就是记者。萨拉·沃威尔讲述了一个关于中间人眼中的世界与非新闻工作者眼中的世界有何不同的寓言。
It all started when Joanne McGlynn's media literacy class at Concord High School invited all the presidential candidates to speak. Known to loiter in New Hampshire ceaselessly before the state's primary elections, a whopping 50% of the eight major candidates accepted. Alan Keyes, Orrin Hatch, Gary Bauer, and Al Gore. They were asked to speak on the subject of school violence, not just because of the killings at Columbine but also because a Concord High School student was killed at school a couple of years ago.
这一切始于康科德高中乔安妮·麦格林（Joanne McGlynn）的媒体素养班邀请所有总统候选人来演讲。众所周知，在州初选前，候选人们会不断在新罕布什尔州徘徊，八位主要候选人中有高达50%的人接受了邀请。艾伦·凯耶斯、奥林·哈奇、加里·鲍尔和阿尔·戈尔。他们被要求谈论校园暴力，不仅是因为科伦拜校园枪击事件，还因为几年前康科德高中的一名学生在校内被杀。
Gore spoke to the student body on November 30, 1999, and contrary to conventional wisdom regarding his charisma deficiency, he was a hit. Students Lucas Gallo, Ashley Pettingill, and Alyssa Spellman recalled the event.
戈尔于1999年11月30日向学生发表了演讲，与外界对他缺乏魅力的传统看法相反，他大受欢迎。学生卢卡斯·加洛、阿什利·佩廷吉尔和艾莉莎·斯佩尔曼回忆了这次活动。
He wasn't as stiff as people say he was. He comes out, takes his jacket off or whatever. He walks around, he asks for audience participation, he talks to the audience.
他并不像人们说的那样死板。他走出来，脱掉外套什么的。他走来走去，要求观众参与，与观众交谈。
There's a question that said, what do you like to do for fun? And he mentioned that he liked The Simpsons.
有一个问题是，你喜欢做什么来消遣？他提到他喜欢《辛普森一家》。
He kind of understood that we are people, we are kids, but we're not dumb. We understand what's going on. And he respected that.
他似乎明白我们是人，我们是孩子，但我们不傻。我们明白发生了什么。他尊重这一点。
I mean, he was still Gore. But he wasn't quite as stiff as like-- he didn't just get up and talk like the other candidates did. He's kind of a neat speaker to see.
我的意思是，他仍然是戈尔。但他并不像其他候选人那样——他不是站起来就开始照本宣科。他是一个很有趣的演讲者。
While the students were impressed by Gore's easygoing manner, his form, Joanne McGlynn was pleased with his content, the way he talked about school violence.
当学生们对戈尔随和的态度和形式印象深刻时，乔安妮·麦格林对他的内容感到满意，特别是他谈论校园暴力的方式。
He was very careful, I think, to describe the complicated nature of what might have caused what happened at Columbine. He didn't say, it is just because those two boys played video games. He used a little analogy about when you catch a cold or when you don't. And he said that some kids in this auditorium had the insulation of a loving family, of teachers that cared about them, of a supportive school system, and said they perhaps were insulated from some of these outside forces and therefore were immune from committing those kinds of acts.
我认为他非常小心地描述了导致科伦拜事件发生的复杂原因。他没有说，这仅仅是因为那两个男孩玩了电子游戏。他用了一个关于你是否会感冒的小类比。他说，礼堂里的一些孩子拥有充满爱的家庭、关心他们的老师以及支持性的学校系统的保护，他说他们可能与这些外部力量隔绝，因此对实施这类行为有了免疫力。
Then during the question and answer period, something happened that seemed unremarkable at the time.
然后在问答环节，发生了一件当时看起来并不引人注目的事情。
Hello, my name is Shane Fletcher, and I want to ask you a question. How do you get students to get involved in more politics?
你好，我叫谢恩·弗莱彻，我想问你一个问题。你是如何让学生们更多地参与政治的？
Hm.
嗯。
He answered in a very lengthy response. He thought for a moment, paused, and said, I know there's a lot of cynicism in the country right now. And he said, especially among young people. He said, I think that it's caused by a number of things. He said, one of them may be that we need campaign finance reform. And he went on and talked about how he supported McCain-Feingold. He then said, but I think you kids should look in the mirror.
他回答得很长。他思考了一会儿，停顿了一下，说，我知道现在全国有很多愤世嫉俗的情绪。他说，特别是在年轻人中。他说，我认为这是由许多事情引起的。他说，其中之一可能是我们需要竞选财务改革。他接着谈到他如何支持麦凯恩-费恩戈尔德法案。然后他说，但我认为你们这些孩子应该照照镜子。
And I think that leaders can make a difference, but I think you also have to examine your own hearts. We are so privileged to live in this country. If that sounds corny to you, you should examine that attitude. Seriously.
我认为领导人可以有所作为，但我也认为你们必须审视自己的内心。我们生活在这个国家是多么幸运。如果这听起来很陈腐，你们应该审视一下这种态度。认真地说。
Think about South Africa. They just recently became a democracy. When they had their first election, you know what the percentage turnout was? It was like 95%. People waited in lines to vote that were seven miles long. Here we have a constantly declining voter turnout. I think it's because a lot of people feel like they cannot make an individual difference. But you can.
想想南非。他们最近才成为民主国家。当他们举行第一次选举时，你知道投票率是多少吗？大约是95%。人们排着七英里长的队去投票。在这里，我们的选民投票率却在持续下降。我认为这是因为很多人觉得他们无法通过个人做出改变。但你们可以。
So he challenged them to get involved. And then he said, let me tell you a little story.
所以他挑战他们去参与。然后他说，让我给你们讲个小故事。
Now I'm going to play you that little story. In the days that followed Gore's appearance, this story was twisted, distorted, and ultimately more fought over than a piece of Jerusalem real estate, which is why I am going to play what he said in its entirety.
现在我要给你们播放那个小故事。在戈尔露面后的几天里，这个故事被扭曲、歪曲，最终变得比耶路撒冷的一块地皮更引人争议，这就是为什么我要播放他所说的全部内容。
Let me tell you a quick story. Twenty years ago, I got a letter from a high school student in West Tennessee about how the water-- her family was drinking from a well-- tasted funny. She wrote me how her grandfather had a mysterious ailment that paralyzed part of his body that she was convinced was related to the water. Then her father also became mysteriously ill. People thought she was imagining things.
让我给你们讲个快故事。二十年前，我收到了一封来自田纳西州西部一名高中生的信，关于她家人从水井里喝的水尝起来很奇怪。她写信告诉我，她祖父患有一种神秘的疾病，导致身体部分瘫痪，她确信这与水有关。然后她的父亲也神秘地病倒了。人们以为她在胡思乱想。
We investigated. And what we found was that one mile from her home, a chemical company had dug a big trench, and they were dumping millions of gallons of hazardous chemical waste into the ground. It had seeped down into the water table and contaminated her family's well and the wells of other families in that rural area.
我们进行了调查。我们发现，离她家一英里远的地方，一家化学公司挖了一条大沟，他们往地下倾倒了数百万加仑的危险化学废料。这些废料渗入了地下水位，污染了她家的水井以及该农村地区其他家庭的水井。
I called for a congressional investigation and a hearing. I looked around the country for other sites like that. I found a little place in upstate New York called Love Canal. Had the first hearing on that issue in Toone-Teague, Tennessee. That was the one you didn't hear of. But that was the one that started it all. We passed a major national law to clean up hazardous dump sites. And we had new efforts to stop the practices that ended up poisoning water around the country. We've still got work to do. But we've made a huge difference. And it all happened because one high school student got involved.
我要求进行国会调查和听证会。我在全国范围内寻找其他类似的地方。我在纽约州北部发现了一个叫拉夫运河（Love Canal）的小地方。我在田纳西州的图恩-蒂格（Toone-Teague）就该问题举行了第一次听证会。那是你们没听说过的那一次。但那正是开启了一切的那一次。我们通过了一项重大的国家法律来清理危险废料堆放点。我们有了新的努力来阻止最终导致全国水质中毒的做法。我们仍有工作要做。但我们已经做出了巨大的改变。而这一切之所以发生，是因为一名高中生参与了进来。
The night after the speech, Joanne McGlynn was at home and a friend called her, asking if she'd seen The New York Times .
演讲后的第二天晚上，乔安妮·麦格林在家时，一位朋友打电话给她，问她有没有看《纽约时报》。
He said, did you notice the Love Canal comment? And I said, well, I remember he told a story about Love Canal. He said, well, it kind of is The Times says that Gore's taking credit for finding Love Canal. And I thought, uh-oh. I got a bit nervous. I thought, is that the way this story is going to be covered?
他说，你注意到关于拉夫运河的评论了吗？我说，嗯，我记得他讲了一个关于拉夫运河的故事。他说，好吧，《时报》说戈尔声称自己发现了拉夫运河。我心想，哦不。我有点紧张。我想，难道这个故事以后要这样报道吗？
Let me read from Katharine Seelye's article in The New York Times on December 1. In a 17-paragraph piece about one day in the Gore campaign, four paragraphs are devoted to the Concord High appearance. Seelye quoted Gore, "'I found a little place in upstate New York called Love Canal. I had the first hearing on that issue in Toone, Tennessee,' he said, 'but I was the one that started it all.'" Curiously The Washington Post made the exact same mistake. Also on December 1, Post staff writer Ceci Connolly quoted, "I was the one that started it all."
让我读一下凯瑟琳·西利（Katharine Seelye）12月1日在《纽约时报》上的文章。在一篇关于戈尔竞选一天的17段文章中，有4段专门写了康科德高中的露面。西利引用戈尔的话说：“‘我在纽约北部发现了一个叫拉夫运河的小地方。我就该问题在田纳西州图恩举行了第一次听证会，’他说，‘但我才是开启了一切的那个人。’”奇怪的是，《华盛顿邮报》也犯了同样的错误。同样是在12月1日，邮报特约撰稿人塞西·康诺利（Ceci Connolly）引用道：“我才是开启了一切的那个人。”
We came in once class, and Miss McGlynn was like, you guys are not going to believe this. And she wrote up the quote on the board, and she said, did he say this? And we were like, what, what? Did he say this-- I was the one that started it all? And then we were like, no, he was talking about the girl. That event started it all. And then we looked at all the newspapers, and we were like, wow.
我们上课时，麦格林老师说，你们绝对不会相信这一点。她在黑板上写下了这句话，并说，他真的这么说了吗？我们当时想，什么，什么？他说了这句话——“我才是开启了一切的那个人”吗？然后我们说，没有，他在谈论那个女孩。是那个事件开启了一切。然后我们看了所有的报纸，我们当时就想，哇。
She then played us back the tape that our TV production class had made. And the actual quote was, "that was the one that started it all," referring to the city in Tennessee.
然后她为我们重放了电视制作班制作的录像带。实际引语是，“那是开启了一切的那一个”，指的是田纳西州的那座城市。
We definitely said, we have to do something about this. And we were definitely, I think, shocked that wow, that one little word, one little word totally changed the context and totally changed what everyone thought about it.
我们一致认为，我们必须为此做点什么。而且我认为我们绝对感到震惊，哇，那一个单词，仅仅一个单词就完全改变了语境，完全改变了每个人对这件事的看法。
After The Times and The Post , the Love Canal mistake snowballed. US News & World Report listed "I was the one that started it all" as one of its quotes of the week. And then there was the following little round table on This Week with Sam Donaldson and Cokie Roberts. Among the two hosts, George Stephanopoulos and Bill Kristol.
在《时报》和《邮报》之后，拉夫运河的错误像滚雪球一样扩大。《美国新闻与世界报道》将“我才是开启了一切的那个人”列为本周语录之一。然后是在山姆·唐纳森（Sam Donaldson）和科基·罗伯茨（Cokie Roberts）主持的《本周》节目中的圆桌讨论。在两位主持人之间，还有乔治·斯特凡诺普洛斯（George Stephanopoulos）和比尔·克里斯托尔（Bill Kristol）。
The Late Show with David Letterman dreamed up a list of the Top 10 other achievements also claimed by Al Gore.
大卫·莱特曼的《深夜秀》策划了一份“阿尔·戈尔声称的其他十大成就”列表。
Initially, the students were upset about the misquote. But the more they thought about it and the more they watched the misquote evolve, they were really flabbergasted by the misrepresentation of Gore's appearance at their school.
起初，学生们对误引感到不安。但他们思考得越多，观看误引的演变过程越多，他们就越对戈尔在他们学校露面的失实报道感到震惊。
He was trying to say that kids can make a difference. He was trying to say what so many high school kids in this country don't believe.
他试图说的是孩子可以做出改变。他试图说出这个国家很多高中生不相信的事情。
He's running for president, so he has to be a bit selfish and boost himself when he's speaking. But they totally missed the point of the entire story that he told. He was trying to make it a clear point for us that we need to get involved and that we should and that we can do something to help. And the media just didn't even mention the message that he's trying to explain or anything.
他是在竞选总统，所以他在演讲时必须有点私心，吹捧一下自己。但他们完全曲解了他讲述的整个故事的要点。他试图向我们明确一点，我们需要参与其中，我们应该参与，我们有能力做些事情来提供帮助。而媒体甚至没有提到他试图解释的信息。
The actual quote itself was, I think, completely innocent. It wasn't a look how great I am, look what I did in Love Canal. It was a look how great you can be. That's what his message was, and that's what the papers overlooked.
我认为实际引语本身是完全无辜的。那不是一种“看我多伟大，看我在拉夫运河做了什么”的姿态。而是一种“看你们能有多伟大”的意图。那是他的信息，而这正是报纸所忽略的。
But what if I was this reporter and I said, I'm sorry, miss. Yes, you're right. I did misquote that. But so what? I still got the gist of what he was doing right. Maybe he was trying to inspire you. That's one part of what he was saying. But the second part of what he was saying is I was the one who brought this to fruition. I, Al Gore. Look at me.
但如果我是这位记者，如果我说，对不起，女士。是的，你是对的。我确实引错了。但这又怎样？我仍然抓住了他所做之事的要点。也许他试图激励你们。那是他所说的一部分。但他说的是我把这件事带到了成功的地步。我，阿尔·戈尔。看看我。
I would say you're wrong. You're focusing on one little itty-bitty microscopic thing that, when misquoted, can mean something completely different, but when quoted correctly, it means a great thing for democracy and things like that.
我会说你错了。你只关注一个微小的、显微镜下才能看到的东西，当被误引时，它意味着完全不同的东西，但当引用正确时，它对民主等事情有着伟大的意义。
If I can come clean on whom I identify with the most in this story, it isn't the students or their teacher. I identify with the New York Times reporter Katharine Seelye, who misheard a word. She was the one that started it all. I am convinced that this woman, whose job it is to follow around a man with two jobs, running for president and being vice president, is beyond overworked. I know this partly because the first chance she got to return my phone call about all of this was at 1:15 in the morning. This poor reporter, this gatekeeper of democracy, was getting her first break of the day in the middle of the night. And considering that I am a writer who has publicly misspelled names, confused Sinclair Lewis with Upton Sinclair, and gotten who knows how many things wrong over the years, I am one pot who should not be calling The Grey Lady black.
如果我能坦白在这件事中我最认同谁，那既不是学生也不是他们的老师。我认同的是《纽约时报》记者凯瑟琳·西利（Katharine Seelye），她听错了一个词。她才是开启了一切的那个人。我确信这位女士，她的工作是跟随一个身兼两职的人（竞选总统和担任副总统），已经不仅仅是过度劳累了。我之所以这样说，部分原因是她第一次能回复我关于这一切的电话是在凌晨1点15分。这位可怜的记者，这位民主的把关人，在深夜里得到了这一天难得的喘息机会。考虑到我本人也是一位作家，我曾公开写错名字，把辛克莱·刘易斯（Sinclair Lewis）和厄普顿·辛克莱（Upton Sinclair）搞混，多年来还弄错了不少事情，我这个“锅”就不应该去说“黑”了。
Both The New York Times and The Washington Post did publish corrections. And this is what Seelye told me. About the students of Concord High, she said, "These kids are well intentioned. They're paying attention. We did get one word wrong. But they're magnifying what happened. Gore did say, 'I found a little town in upstate New York called Love Canal.'" She continued, "He called the AP in Buffalo the next day and apologized for presuming to take credit for that."
《纽约时报》和《华盛顿邮报》确实都发布了更正。这就是西利告诉我的。关于康科德高中的学生，她说：“这些孩子动机良好。他们在关注。我们确实错了一个词。但他们在放大这件事。戈尔确实说过，‘我在纽约北部发现了一个叫拉夫运河的小镇。’”她继续说道，“第二天他给布法罗的美联社打了电话，为冒昧地声称功劳表示了道歉。”
The journalists were, in fact, correct when they said that Love Canal was already a front-page story, an official national emergency months before Al Gore ever held hearings. But as you heard yourself, Gore never claimed to have been the one to have first brought Love Canal to national attention. He only claimed to have held the first congressional hearings on it.
事实上，当记者们说拉夫运河在阿尔·戈尔举行听证会前几个月就已经是一则头条新闻，是一个官方的国家紧急事件时，他们是正确的。但正如你们亲自听到的，戈尔从未声称自己是第一个将拉夫运河带入全国视野的人。他只声称就该问题举行了第一次国会听证会。
I think what shocks me, though, is that there seems, on some parts of the media that we've talked to, very little remorse. That surprises me, that it was just a word. I guess I have my own bias or perception as I look at the event.
然而，让我感到震惊的是，在我们谈过的部分媒体中，似乎几乎没有悔意。这让我很惊讶，那仅仅是一个词。我想我在看待这件事时有我自己的偏见或认知。
The week before Al Gore came, our entire school had to practice a lockdown procedure. And a lockdown procedure is something I had never experienced except as a kid in Catholic school in Rhode Island in the early '60s. The nuns had us hiding under our desks or putting our heads down to protect us from nuclear fallout from when the Russians were going to bomb us.
在阿尔·戈尔来之前的那周，我们整个学校不得不练习封锁程序。封锁程序是我在60年代初在罗德岛的天主教学校作为孩子时从未经历过的体验。修女们让我们躲在课桌下，或者低头保护自己，以应对当俄国人要轰炸我们时的核辐射。
And now in 1999, we are-- or we were in 1999-- being asked to run through an event as though a sniper were out in the hallway. This came down as a recommendation from the state of New Hampshire, their safety planning group. And it just so happened that we had our first practice session the week before Al Gore came to Concord High School.
而现在在1999年，我们——或者说我们在1999年——被要求进行演习，就好像走廊里有一个狙击手一样。这是新罕布什尔州安全规划小组的建议。恰好我们在阿尔·戈尔来到康科德高中前一周进行了第一次练习。
So our principal came over the intercom and said, teachers, please implement the lockdown procedure. We knew ahead of time this was going to happen sometime during the next two days. I had to take my freshmen and move them away from the door, get them on the floor, turn their desks on their sides so they would be protected as much as they could be in case someone came into the room or attempted to come into the room with a gun. We had to be silent. I had to go out in the hallway and lock the door and grab any kid who might have been returning from the bathroom, hoping this kid was not the person that we needed to worry about, grab that kid, pull them in, and ask my students to be quiet.
所以校长通过对讲机说，老师们，请执行封锁程序。我们提前知道这两天内会发生这种情况。我不得不带着我的新生远离门口，让他们趴在地上，把课桌侧过来，这样如果有人进来或试图带着枪进入房间，他们就能得到尽可能多的保护。我们必须保持安静。我不得不走到走廊上锁门，抓住任何可能从洗手间回来的孩子，希望这个孩子不是我们需要担心的那个人，抓住那个孩子，把他们拉进来，并让我的学生保持安静。
I have to tell you, it was very unsettling. The thought that one of our students could be out in the hallway trying to harm us, it's a very complicated emotional response. Many of us were very uncomfortable during the lockdown-- but couldn't show that to the kids, wanted to show the kids that they were safe and not to worry.
我必须告诉你们，这非常令人不安。想到我们的学生中可能有人在走廊里试图伤害我们，这是一种非常复杂的情绪反应。我们在封锁期间感到非常不舒服——但不能向孩子们表现出来，我想向孩子们展示他们是安全的，不要担心。
So I thought Gore did a good job talking about this issue. I thought this was an issue that should be one of the prime ones in our presidential campaign. And I feared immediately when I heard Love Canal that somehow what had happened at Concord High would become a joke. And in some ways, that is what happened.
所以我认为戈尔在谈论这个问题上做得很好。我认为这是一个应该成为我们总统竞选中首要议题的问题。当我听到拉夫运河时，我立刻担心康科德高中发生的事情会以某种方式变成一个笑话。在某些方面，确实就是那样。
It just makes me sad that the wise-guy attitude seems to dominate the press right now. And that's what I pick up on. Not to pick on Chris Matthews, but he spent two nights having a blast with this story about Love Canal, getting a big chuckle out of Dan Quayle may not be able to spell potato, but now Al Gore's going to claim he invented it. Chris Matthews refers to Al Gore as Zelig.
我只是感到难过，因为现在媒体中似乎盛行这种“聪明人”的态度。这就是我所感受到的。不是要针对克里斯·马修斯（Chris Matthews），但他花了两个晚上兴致勃勃地拿拉夫运河的故事开玩笑，觉得“丹·奎尔可能不会拼写土豆（potato），但现在阿尔·戈尔要声称他发明了它”很有趣。克里斯·马修斯将阿尔·戈尔称为“变色龙（Zelig）”。
I think he has Edmund Morris writing his speeches for him.
我认为他让埃德蒙·莫里斯（Edmund Morris）为他写演讲稿。
Well, maybe where Chris works, that seemed like a funny thing to say. But where I work, it didn't seem that funny. Where I work, hiding some day, pretending to be hiding behind desks with kids, afraid that Klebold and Harris are outside my door, it didn't seem that funny. It really didn't seem that funny. And I'm not saying our candidates should be untested, unquestioned, uncriticized. I'm not saying that in the least. But I am saying if that's all we do, and if all we do is make fun of them, then we're losing something too, I think.
好吧，也许在克里斯工作的地方，这听起来像是个有趣的说法。但在我工作的地方，这看起来并不那么好笑。在我工作的地方，有一天躲起来，假装和孩子们躲在桌子后面，害怕科伦拜的枪手在门外，这看起来并不那么好笑。这真的看起来并不那么好笑。我并不是说我们的候选人应该未经考验、不受质疑、不被批评。我一点也不这么说。但我是在说，如果这就是我们所做的一切，如果这就是我们所做的一切就是嘲笑他们，那么我认为我们也正在失去某些东西。
I feel like some reporters are just printing stuff that doesn't promote anybody anymore. They're just saying what they did wrong.
我觉得有些记者印刷的东西已经不再能促进任何人的利益了。他们只是在说他们做错了什么。
I asked 16-year-old Ashley Pettingill what we lose when the press omits descriptions of how a candidate might actually make a good president.
我问16岁的阿什利·佩廷吉尔（Ashley Pettingill），当媒体省略了对候选人可能如何成为一名好总统的描述时，我们失去了什么。
I think we miss out on every reason to vote for them.
我认为我们失去了所有投票给他们的理由。
At Concord High School, a politician actually spoke inspiringly and connected with the audience, which to me is news. But no reporter reported this. And in fact, these kind of moments are routinely overlooked by the press. They're barely part of our national political discourse.
在康科德高中，一位政客确实发表了鼓舞人心的演讲并与观众建立了联系，这对我来说是新闻。但没有记者报道这件事。事实上，这类时刻经常被媒体忽略。它们几乎不属于我们的国家政治话语。
But why? For one thing, so much political speech is lies, spin, and misrepresentation, it's understandable that journalists report these inspiring moments skeptically, if at all. And beyond that, the way most of the press works is pretty much as you suspect. Representatives of the news media carry around storylines of the candidates in their heads, and reporters light up when reality randomly corroborates these pictures.
但为什么？一方面，太多的政治言论是谎言、公关和歪曲，记者们对这些鼓舞人心的时刻持怀疑态度（如果报道的话）是可以理解的。除此之外，大多数媒体的运作方式和你所怀疑的差不多。新闻媒体的代表们脑子里装着关于候选人的剧情，当现实随机证实这些画面时，记者们就会兴奋起来。
One of the great mysteries of modern politics is which storylines get told and which get ignored. And in the primary season, that storyline is still up for grabs. John McCain's storyline, hero, threatened to become hypocrite in light of his helping a major donor with the FCC. Not long after George W. Bush flunked a foreign policy pop quiz, it appeared his name tag at the Correspondents Dinner was destined to read, "Hello, my name is Dunderhead."
现代政治的一大谜团是哪些剧情会被讲述，哪些会被忽略。而在初选季节，那个剧情仍然是待定的。约翰·麦凯恩的英雄剧情，在得知他帮助一位大捐赠人处理联邦通信委员会（FCC）事务后，面临变成伪君子的风险。在乔治·W·布什搞砸了一次外交政策小测验后不久，他在记者晚宴上的名字牌似乎注定要写上“你好，我叫笨蛋”。
Gore's storyline, that he's a bore, is spiced up by this secondary storyline, that he's a braggart, that he takes credit for ridiculous things, for inventing the internet, and for being the real life Oliver of Love Story. So of course the Love Canal misunderstanding screamed to reporters because it brought this particular fuzzy snapshot of Gore into sharper focus. It is telling that both the reporter for The Times and the one for The Post heard the exact same word incorrectly, almost as if that was what they wanted to hear. Teacher Joanne McGlynn says that this is a seductive impulse for both reporters and voters.
戈尔的“无聊”剧情被这个次要剧情点缀得更丰富了：他是个吹牛大王，他为荒谬的事情邀功，比如发明互联网，以及成为《爱情故事》中现实版的奥利弗。所以拉夫运河的误解自然引起了记者们的尖叫，因为它让这个戈尔的模糊快照变得更加清晰。值得注意的是，《时报》和《邮报》的记者都听错了同一个词，好像这就是他们想听到的。教师乔安妮·麦格林说，这对记者和选民来说都是一种诱人的冲动。
This editor for US News & World Report called and said that-- and this was after he admitted he was sorry that they had published a misquote-- he told me a story about George Bush Sr. running for president in 1992. And I remember the story myself, that George Bush went into a supermarket and was stunned to find a scanner-- I guess he was used to old cash registers-- and made a comment that showed he was surprised to see a scanner.
这位《美国新闻与世界报道》的编辑打电话来说——这是在他承认他很抱歉他们发布了错误引语之后——他给我讲了一个关于老布什在1992年竞选总统的故事。我记得这个故事，布什走进一家超市，惊讶地发现了一个扫描仪——我想他习惯了旧的收银机——并发表了一段评论，显示他看到扫描仪感到惊讶。
What this gentleman from US News & World Report told me was, actually the pool reporter got that story wrong, that it was actually some kind of new scanner that Bush remarked on. But that comment then became the symbol or the iconic moment for Bush being out of touch with Middle America. And that was it. I think that might have hurt Bush big time. Now, it turned out-- if this man is right from US News & World Report-- not to be accurate. Now, if it wasn't accurate, was it not true? I mean, was Bush out of touch with Middle America?
这位《美国新闻与世界报道》的先生告诉我的是，实际上当时的跟队记者弄错了那个故事，那实际上是布什注意到的某种新型扫描仪。但那段评论后来成为了布什脱离美国中产阶级的象征或标志性时刻。就是这样。我认为这可能对布什造成了巨大的伤害。现在，事实证明——如果这位来自《美国新闻与世界报道》的人是对的——这并不准确。现在，如果它不准确，难道它不是真的吗？我的意思是，布什真的脱离了美国中产阶级吗？
It's the same thing going back to Gore. Does Gore take credit? It makes me question. And I have to say, I am going to keep my eyes open in a way I hadn't before, and particularly when things automatically fit my mindset. I'm going to be a little more careful. It' didn't surprise me that maybe President Bush didn't know about a scanner. But if he did, it's too bad that got out there. It's not fair.
这同样适用于戈尔。戈尔真的邀功了吗？这让我产生质疑。我必须说，我要以我以前没有过的方式睁大眼睛观察，特别是在事情自动符合我的心态时。我会更加小心。总统布什可能不知道扫描仪，这并不让我惊讶。但如果他知道，那传出去太可惜了。这不公平。
I looked at Joanne McGlynn's syllabus for her media literacy course, the one she handed out at the beginning of the year stating the goals of the class. By the end of the year, she hoped her students would be better able to challenge everything from novels to newscasts, that they would come to identify just who is telling a story and how that person's point of view affects the story being told.
我看了乔安妮·麦格林媒体素养课程的教学大纲，那是她在年初分发的说明班级目标的材料。到学年末，她希望她的学生能更好地挑战从小说到新闻的一切，他们将能识别到底是谁在讲述故事，以及那个人的观点如何影响所讲述的故事。
I'm going to go out on a limb here and say that this lesson has been learned. In fact, just recently, a student came up to McGlynn and told her something all good teachers dream of hearing. The girl told the teacher that she was listening to the radio, singing along with her favorite song. And halfway through the singalong, she stopped and asked herself, what am I singing? What do these words mean? What are they trying to tell me? And then this young citizen of the republic jokingly complained, I can't even turn on the radio without thinking more.
我在这里冒昧地说，这一课已经学到了。事实上，最近有一个学生找到麦格林，告诉了她所有好老师都梦想听到的事情。那个女孩告诉老师，她在听广播，跟着她最喜欢的歌唱。在合唱到一半时，她停下来问自己，我在唱什么？这些词是什么意思？它们想告诉我什么？然后这位年轻的共和国公民开玩笑地抱怨道，我连打开收音机都无法不去思考。
Sarah Vowell is a columnist for Salon, the online magazine. She has a new collection of essays coming out called Take the Cannoli. Coming up, the finger-wagging styles of presidential candidates throughout history, and how George W. Bush acts in his own car. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
萨拉·沃威尔是在线杂志《沙龙》的专栏作家。她有一本新的文集即将出版，名为《拿走卡诺里》。接下来，历史上总统候选人的手指摇摆风格，以及乔治·W·布什在自己车里的表现。在国际公共广播电台我们的节目继续之后，那一分钟就会揭晓。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Tales from the New Hampshire Primary, stories about why it is so hard for us to feel inspired by and connected to presidential candidates and of people who have managed that trick.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，带给你们关于该主题的各种不同故事。今天的节目，“新罕布什尔州初选的故事”，关于为什么我们很难被总统候选人激励并与他们建立联系，以及那些成功做到这一点的人的故事。
We have arrived at act two of our program. Act Two, The Mask Behind the Mask. The front-runners always seem more protected. They are always the least spontaneous, the most packaged. They have the most to lose from a gaff, after all. And they have more people gunning for them too. Take George W. Bush. In debates, he'll often repeat the same few answers to several different questions. Sarah Koenig has been covering the Bush campaign for months for the newspaper The Concord Monitor in New Hampshire, trying to get to know the real George W. Bush, the man behind the message.
我们已经进入了节目的第二部分。第二部分，“面具背后的面具”。领跑者总是显得受到更多保护。他们总是最不自发、最被包装。毕竟，他们最害怕出错。而且他们也有更多的人针对他们。以乔治·W·布什为例。在辩论中，他经常对几个不同的问题重复相同的几个答案。萨拉·科尼格（Sarah Koenig）在新罕布什尔州的《康科德监测报》报道布什竞选活动已经几个月了，试图了解真实的乔治·W·布什，信息背后的那个人。
I am in Austin, sitting in the back of George W. Bush's dusty blue Lincoln Town Car. He's twisting a gum wrapper around and around his finger, and he's grouchy. He's fighting the flu, I find out later. But right now, I think I must be letting him down somehow.
我在奥斯汀，坐在乔治·W·布什那辆布满灰尘的蓝色林肯城市轿车的后座。他正在把一个口香糖包装纸缠绕在手指上，而且他心情烦躁。我后来发现他在和流感作斗争。但此刻，我以为我一定是在某些方面让他失望了。
Back in his office at the state house, I had asked him about Texas politics and education reform. He seemed bored. His eyes moved around distractedly and his answers were the same ones I had heard him intone on the stump in New Hampshire about the American dream touching every willing heart. Suddenly he announced the interview was over. Bush must have sensed my disappointment because he said I could ride with him from his office to the Governor's mansion if I wanted.
在州议会大厦的办公室里，我问过他关于德克萨斯州政治和教育改革的问题。他看起来很无聊。他的目光心不在焉地四处游移，他的回答和我听他在新罕布什尔州巡回演讲时说的一样，关于美国梦触及每一颗渴望的心。突然，他宣布采访结束了。布什一定感觉到了我的失望，因为他说如果我想的话，我可以跟他坐车从他的办公室到州长官邸。
He sits in the front seat and I sit in back. And after two and a half blocks, we arrive at the mansion. The driver pulls under the portico, but Bush doesn't like where he stops, so he makes him move up a few inches. I consider that a while, those few inches. After covering George Bush for months, this is what I've come to. I'm thinking any move he makes that isn't on a campaign schedule, anything he says that isn't scripted, even something as small as this, might be a clue to figuring out who he really is.
他坐在前座，我坐在后座。两条半街区后，我们到达了官邸。司机把车开到门廊下，但布什不喜欢停车的位置，所以他让他向前移动了几英寸。我琢磨了一会儿那几英寸。在报道了乔治·布什几个月后，我得出了这个结论。我在想，他做的任何不在竞选日程上的动作，他说的任何未经编排的话，甚至是像这样的小事，都可能是解开他真实面目的线索。
In New Hampshire, Bush had been friendly. He even seemed to like me. After just one meeting, he almost remembered who I was. We were next to each other in this heaving mass of reporters and townspeople, and he squinting at me and pointed. Yale, right? No, Governor, I said, almost. Then I think he asked my name, and after that, he knew who I was.
在新罕布什尔州，布什一直很友好。他似乎甚至喜欢我。仅一次会面后，他就几乎记住了我是谁。我们在挤满记者和镇民的人群中，他眯着眼看着我，指了指我。耶鲁，对吧？不，州长，我说，差不多。然后我想他问了我的名字，之后他就知道我是谁了。
He would wink at me from the vortex of huge crowds. Once he walked past me on his way to deliver a speech about education policy and he pinched my elbow. When I was on his bus with some other reporters, he patted my knee. This wasn't flirting. It was a kind of affectionate teasing. It's a side of George Bush you don't see on television. You don't see how he leans in so close to people he looks as if he's going to kiss them. You don't hear the nicknames, the wisecracks, the asides.
他会从巨大的人群漩涡中对我眨眼。有一次他走过我身边去发表关于教育政策的演讲，他捏了捏我的手肘。当我和其他记者在车上时，他拍了拍我的膝盖。这不是调情。这是一种亲昵的戏弄。这是你在电视上看不到的乔治·布什的一面。你没看到他如何凑近人们，看起来他好像要亲他们一样。你听不到那些绰号、俏皮话和题外话。
But off screen, he bestows them liberally, especially to the press. A baby would cry and he'd blame the guy from The Houston Chronicle . He'd make the New York Times reporter giggle by telling him to get a haircut.
但在镜头外，他大方地施予这些，尤其是对媒体。如果婴儿哭了，他会怪《休斯顿纪事报》的那家伙。《纽约时报》的记者被他叫去剪头发而咯咯笑。
So here we are in Austin, parked in front of the mansion, sitting in the Lincoln Town Car, and despite our chummy rapport, the interview is proceeding miserably. Our conversation is petering out, and I think he's going to ditch any second. But he doesn't. Instead, he faces the windshield and his voice gets quiet.
所以我们现在在奥斯汀，停在官邸前，坐在林肯轿车里，尽管我们关系融洽，但采访进行得一塌糊涂。我们的谈话正在逐渐枯竭，我想他随时都会把我甩掉。但他没有。相反，他面对挡风玻璃，声音变得安静。
And that's when he mentions his nest. He likes campaigning, he says, but he longs for the comforting feeling of being around his own cats and dog. "One thing about campaigning that I miss is not being in my nest," he says. It occurs to me that this is perhaps the first thing he's ever said to me that he hasn't said to anyone else.
就在那时，他提到了他的“窝”。他说他喜欢竞选，但他渴望那种在自己的猫和狗身边的舒适感。“关于竞选，我错过的一件事就是没有待在我的窝里，”他说。我突然想到，这可能是他对我说的第一句他没对任何人说过的话。
His aides tell me to be at the mansion at 6:00 AM the next day if I want to observe Bush being interviewed by a 10-year-old. I go. In a fatherly tone, he recites for the boy the same platform points that have already saturated the national news, including that kid-friendly one about developing anti-ballistic missile systems. Afterward, we chat in one of the period sitting rooms, and Bush elaborates on his nesting pattern. He's the first up, he walks the dog, he feeds the little cat that sleeps inside, he lets in the yellow cat that sleeps outside, he feeds the little black cat that stays outside all the time, he makes coffee and brings it to the First Lady, they read newspapers in the sack. Then he has a light breakfast and gets dressed and wanders around the house looking for something to do. He's at work by 7:30 or 8:00.
他的助手让我第二天早上6点到官邸，如果我想观察布什接受一个10岁孩子的采访的话。我去了。他用一种父亲般的语气给那个男孩背诵了已经充斥全国新闻的同样的竞选纲领要点，包括那个关于开发反弹道导弹系统的适合儿童的要点。之后，我们在一个陈列室风格的客厅里聊天，布什详细阐述了他的“筑巢模式”。他是第一个起床的，他遛狗，喂睡在里面的那只小猫，放睡在外面的那只黄猫进来，喂那只一直待在外面的小黑猫，他煮咖啡并给第一夫人端去，他们在被窝里读报纸。然后他吃一点清淡的早餐，穿好衣服，在屋子里徘徊寻找要做的事。他通常在7点半或8点开始工作。
I tell him I'm impressed and that I'm tired. It's now 6:30 in the morning. He asks me how old I am. Thirty, I tell him. See, I was sluggish, too, at 30, he says. He tells me by the time I'm his age, 53, I'll be more energetic. Your biological clock, he says, it's like clockwork.
我告诉他我很佩服他，而且我很累。现在是早上6点半。他问我多大。30岁，我告诉他。看，我在30岁时也很迟钝，他说。他告诉我，等我到了他这个年龄，53岁，我会更有活力。你的生物钟，他说，就像发条一样。
Maybe I have just glimpsed the real George Bush. Maybe the real George Bush talks about his nest. Weeks later, I ask one of Bush's aides about it.
也许我刚刚瞥见了真实的乔治·布什。也许真实的乔治·布什会谈论他的窝。几周后，我问了布什的一位助手关于这件事的情况。
And I'm asking if he's said that before.
我问他以前是否说过这些。
Yes, he has said that before. He says he likes his routine. He likes getting up in the morning, letting the dog out, playing with the dogs, feeding the cats, picking up the newspapers, going upstairs, making some coffee, reading the newspapers.
是的，他以前说过。他说他喜欢他的惯例。他喜欢早上起床，让狗出去，和狗玩，喂猫，捡报纸，上楼，煮咖啡，读报纸。
Has he used the word nest?
他用过“窝”这个词吗？
I believe he's used the word nest before.
我相信他以前用过“窝”这个词。
In one sense, you want to give Bush and all these politicians a break. They have to talk to scores of people every day, and they're trying to win over every single one. It's like trying to land a date with an entire village. How many charming stories, stories that we'd be willing to broadcast, stories that have to be personal but not too personal, does any of us have? A dozen? A half dozen?
从某种意义上说，你想给布什和所有这些政客一个机会。他们每天必须与很多人交谈，他们试图赢取每一个人的支持。这就像试图与整个村庄约会一样。我们每个人有多少迷人的故事，我们愿意广播的故事，必须是私人的但又不能太私人的故事？十二个？半打？
I figured if Bush was not in a position to tell me who he was, maybe people who had been around him in Texas could. I called Harvey Kronberg, a veteran political reporter who describes himself, like many Texans do, as a liberal Republican or a moderate Democrat. Kronberg tells me the Texas press had the same difficulty getting to know Bush when he was first running for governor.
我想，如果布什没能告诉我他是谁，也许那些在德克萨斯州了解他的人可以。我打电话给哈维·克朗伯格（Harvey Kronberg），一位资深政治记者，像许多德克萨斯人一样，他形容自己是自由派共和党人或温和派民主党人。克朗伯格告诉我，当布什第一次竞选州长时，德克萨斯媒体在了解他方面也有同样的困难。
He had a standard stump speech. And at that time, he was running on four principles, juvenile justice reform, education reform, tort reform, and welfare reform. And you just could not break him off of those four items on his agenda. You would ask about him about the weather and it would ultimately lead back to education reform or tort reform.
他有一套标准的竞选演讲。那时，他竞选的原则有四个：少年司法改革、教育改革、侵权改革和福利改革。你根本无法让他脱离他议程上的这四项内容。你会问他天气如何，他最终还是会引向教育改革或侵权改革。
It was very frustrating, and you began to suspect, like folks are suspecting now, there might be less there than meets the eye. From the press corps position, we were all pretty doubtful, I think, going into his first legislative session as to whether he had the mental horsepower to pull it off. Of course, we were pleasantly surprised as the session progressed.
这非常令人沮丧，你会开始怀疑，就像人们现在怀疑的那样，这里可能没那么深。从媒体团的角度来看，我认为在我们进入他第一次立法会议时，我们都相当怀疑他是否有足够的智力来完成任务。当然，随着会议的进展，我们感到惊喜。
Kronberg said once he took office, Bush loosened up and understood the state's business as shrewdly as any of his predecessors. Sadly, for us non-Texans, now that Bush is again running for office, he's back on message in every conversation except when he's either joking around or annoyed. Those are the moments when Bush seems most real to me. In moments of irritation, you can glimpse his vulnerability, his youth, even.
克朗伯格说，他上任后，布什变得放松，并像他的任何前任一样精明地处理州务。可惜对于我们这些非德克萨斯人来说，现在布什再次竞选公职，他回到了一切谈话的中心，除非他是在开玩笑或感到恼火。那些时刻是我觉得布什最真实的时刻。在烦躁的时刻，你可以瞥见他的脆弱，甚至是他的年轻。
Back in New Hampshire, I make another attempt to slip behind the sound bites. I know he reads the Bible every day, and I decide to ask him about it. I borrow a Gideon Bible from a Holiday Inn and bring it to a press availability in Portsmouth. Is there a particular passage he turns to for strength? I ask him.
在新罕布什尔州，我又尝试了一次超越音讯片段的努力。我知道他每天读圣经，我决定问问他。我从假日酒店借了一本基甸圣经，带到了朴次茅斯的一个新闻发布会现场。有没有什么特定的段落是他寻求力量时会翻看的？我问。
As a matter of fact, I'm reading Matthew right now. And one of the great parts of Matthew is the fifth chapter called the Beatitudes. And I think it's good that people read the Beatitudes, no matter what your religion may be. The interesting thing about religion and politics-- I answer questions about my religion because I'm mindful of what happens in politics. When politicians say vote for me, I'm superior to you. That's not what I'm saying. As a matter of fact, I'm coming from the different perspective. I want people to know that I'm a person who seeks religion because I realize I, too, am a sinner. And I, too, need strength.
事实上，我正在读马太福音。马太福音中伟大的部分之一是第五章，称为“八福”。我认为无论你的宗教信仰如何，人们阅读“八福”是件好事。关于宗教和政治有趣的事情是——我回答关于我的宗教的问题是因为我注意到了政治中发生的事情。当政客们说“投票给我，我比你们优越”时。那不是我要说的。事实上，我来自不同的视角。我想让人们知道，我是一个寻求宗教的人，因为我意识到我本人也是个罪人。而且，我也需要力量。
Is there a part that you can find?
有没有你可以找到的部分？
You mean to show you where the Beatitudes are?
你是想让我给你展示“八福”在哪里吗？
Yeah, or where you are right now.
是的，或者你现在读到的地方。
Is this a test?
这是一个测试吗？
No, it's not a test. A Bible test. I haven't  read it, so I couldn't possibly test you.
不，这不是测试。圣经测试。我没读过，所以我不可能会测试你。
You've never read the Bible?
你从来没读过圣经？
I admit I have never.
我承认我从未读过。
That's OK. I still like you as a person.
没关系。我仍然喜欢你这个人。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Thank you.
谢谢。
I'm more worried about your stories I'm in than whether you've read the Bible. No, I'm teasing you. Where am I now? I was reading about the house divided upon itself. Let me see here. Hold on a second. I'll run upstairs and get my Bible where it's marked. Sarah, I don't think you think I read the Bible, do you?
我更担心的是我出现在你的故事里，而不是你是否读过圣经。不，我在逗你。我现在在哪？我在读关于自相纷争的家。让我看看。等一下。我上楼去把我的圣经拿来，那里有标记。萨拉，我不认为你觉得我读过圣经，对吗？
No, I think you do.
不，我觉得你读过。
OK, good.
好吧，很好。
Why don't you think that I think you do?
为什么你不认为我觉得你读过呢？
Well, I'm just curious. This is kind of a very interesting line of questioning for me to show you where I am exactly in the Bible this morning. It's just interesting. It's never happened before in the midst of a presidential campaign. At any rate--
好吧，我只是好奇。这对我来说是一个非常有趣的提问方式，要让我向你展示我今天早上圣经读到哪里了。这很有趣。在总统竞选中从未发生过。无论如何——
He finds the section he's looking for and holds it up so everyone can see. We all nod. Finally, I ask him outright how close the real George Bush is to the one we see campaigning, if there are parts of himself he withholds from the public.
他找到了他要找的部分，并把它举起来让每个人都能看到。我们都点了点头。最后，我直接问他真实的乔治·布什与我们看到的竞选中的布什有多接近，他是否对自己有所隐瞒。
This isn't falling into psychobabble, is it?
这不会变成心理分析吧？
I don't know. You tell me.
我不知道。你告诉我。
That's a very interesting question, Sarah. If there were, I don't think I could-- this is a process that pretty much over time exposes all. I think it's very hard to be a private person in the midst of a very public campaign. And if you're watching me very closely, you'll get glimpses into my heart and what makes me tick over time.
这是一个非常有趣的问题，萨拉。如果真的有的话，我不认为我能——这是一个随着时间推移几乎会暴露一切的过程。我认为在一个非常公开的竞选中做一个私人是非常困难的。如果你非常仔细地观察我，随着时间的推移，你将获得窥见我内心深处以及是什么让我动力的机会。
His wife, Laura, gently knocks on the door and comes in.
他的妻子劳拉轻轻敲了敲门走了进来。
There I was, just getting-- I was psycho-babbling much more than your ever dreamt. The question was would you care to psycho-babble about yourself? Anyway, there are moments when I like to be alone. I bet you people don't know about me that I am a person of routines around the house. I will give you a routine that I miss a lot, and that's early morning. I love to wake up, particularly if I had some sleep, and the first thing that happens is one of the cats will kind of come up and jump on the bed. This is the indoor-- we have three cats, two that stay outside at night, one that stays inside. And we have one dog that stays inside at night, and outside during the day. Anyway-- and I walk down to the kitchen feeder, I turn on the coffee--
我当时就想，我也——我比你想象的更在进行心理分析。问题是你想对自己进行心理分析吗？不管怎样，有些时刻我喜欢一个人待着。我敢打赌你们不知道关于我的一点是，我是家里按部就班的人。我会给你一个我非常怀念的惯例，那就是清晨。我喜欢醒来，特别是在睡够了的情况下，第一件事就是其中一只猫会跳上床。这是室内的——我们有三只猫，两只晚上待在外面，一只待在室内。我们有一条狗晚上待在室内，白天待在室外。不管怎样——我走下楼去厨房喂食，我打开咖啡——
Everyone I talk to about Bush, his friends, his colleagues, his brother Jeb, said the man they know is the same at home as he is at work, the same one we see. After watching him for months, I think that's probably true with one caveat. For now, every story he tells in public has a purpose.
每一个我谈到布什的人，他的朋友、同事，他的兄弟杰布，都说他们认识的这个人在家里和在工作中是一样的，和我们看到的一样。在观察了他几个月后，我认为这可能是真的，但有一个警告。目前，他在公共场合讲述的每一个故事都有一个目的。
Take the nesting story. Once I've heard it three times, I finally realize Bush's message is this. I do not snort cocaine or dance naked on table tops. I might live in a mansion, but I make my own coffee. I do not think the presidency is my birthright. I am a humble, loving family man, satisfied by simple pleasures such as providing for those meeker than myself, like my pets.
以“筑巢”故事为例。当我听了三次后，我终于意识到布什的信息是这样的：我不会吸食可卡因，也不会在桌子上裸舞。我可能住在官邸里，但我自己煮咖啡。我不认为总统职位是我的与生俱来的权利。我是一个谦逊、充满爱的顾家男人，满足于像照顾比我弱小的生物（比如我的宠物）这样简单的快乐。
I love my home. I love my nest. I don't mind sharing that with you, because I understand how public my life is in the course of a campaign.
我爱我的家。我爱我的“窝”。我不介意与你们分享，因为我理解我的生活在竞选过程中是多么公开。
Sarah Koenig is a political reporter for The Concord Monitor.
萨拉·科尼格是《康科德监测报》的政治记者。
[MUSIC - "NO ONE WILL EVER KNOW" BY HANK WILLIAMS, SR.]
[音乐 - 汉克·威廉姆斯演唱的《NO ONE WILL EVER KNOW》]
Act Three. Pay No Attention to the Man Behind the Mosh Pit. In this cynical age, we end our show today with a story of citizens who feel perfectly connected to their candidate of choice, who feel inspired by him. This American Life producer Alex Blumberg tells this story.
第三部分，“别注意人潮背后的候选人”。在这个愤世嫉俗的时代，我们今天以一个故事结束我们的节目，讲述那些与他们选择的候选人感到完全联系、并被他激励的公民。本节目制片人亚历克斯·布隆伯格讲述了这个故事。
Let's play a little game. I'll describe a group of people, you guess the candidate they support. Ready? It's a couple of dozen teenagers outside the presidential primary debates in Durham, New Hampshire. They're all wearing bright orange t-shirts, talking about punk rock and skateboarding in the freezing cold. One of the kids is wearing nothing but jeans and a t-shirt. Give up?
让我们玩个小游戏。我描述一群人，你们猜他们支持哪位候选人。准备好了吗？在 Durham, New Hampshire 的总统初选辩论现场外有几十个青少年。他们都穿着亮橙色的T恤，在严寒中谈论朋克摇滚和滑板。其中一个孩子只穿了牛仔裤和T恤。放弃吗？
It's pretty cold out here, but I'm freezing for a reason. And that reason is Steve Forbes!
外面很冷，但我冷是有原因的。那个原因就是史蒂夫·福布斯！
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
Freezing for a reason! Freezing for a reason! Freezing for a reason!
冷得有理由！冷得有理由！冷得有理由！
Steve Forbes!
史蒂夫·福布斯！
Meet Youth for Forbes.
认识一下“福布斯青年团”。
Freezing for a reason!
冷得有理由！
Steve Forbes!
史蒂夫·福布斯！
A group of young people so psyched about their millionaire publisher candidate that they'll burst into spontaneous cheering at the slightest provocation. Witness this exchange.
一群年轻人对他们的百万富翁出版商候选人如此兴奋，以至于他们会在最轻微的刺激下爆发出自发的欢呼。看看这段对话。
So where are you guys going now?
那么你们现在要去哪儿？
To a party for Steve Forbes!
去参加史蒂夫·福布斯的派对！
We're going to Huddleston Hall. We're going to party for Steve Forbes.
我们要去哈德尔斯顿大厅。我们要去为史蒂夫·福布斯开派对。
All right, can I come with you guys?
好的，我可以跟你们一起去吗？
Absolutely.
当然可以。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
Maybe there are hard-bitten reporters out there who could resist such an enthusiastic reception, but I am not one of them. As we walk to their van from the debate site, I establish a few facts. They're not paid, they get no school credit, and though they're almost all from Republican families, their parents have absolutely nothing to do with the fact that they're volunteering. Very few of their parents even support Steve Forbes. These kids are here because in their view, nothing could be more fun.
也许有那种饱经风霜的记者能够抵御如此热情的接待，但我不是其中之一。当我们从辩论现场走向他们的面包车时，我确认了一些事实。他们没有报酬，没有学校学分，尽管他们几乎都来自共和党家庭，但他们的父母与他们做志愿者这件事完全无关。他们中很少有人的父母甚至支持史蒂夫·福布斯。这些孩子在这里是因为在他们看来，没有什么比这更有趣了。
We get to the hall where New Hampshire's Forbes supporters have gathered to watch the debate on a big screen TV. It's striking that of the almost 200 people here, fully half of them aren't old enough to vote. The Forbes campaign claims to have the biggest Republican youth organization in New Hampshire. And when you go to campaign events, this claim seems believable. There are always more young people there for Forbes, which is incredible when you think about it. Steve Forbes, the flat tax candidate? I mean, can there be an issue less likely to inspire the nation's youth than the US tax code? Most teenagers haven't even seen a 1040 form.
我们到达了新罕布什尔州的福布斯支持者聚集在大屏幕电视前观看辩论的大厅。令人震惊的是，在场的近200人中，有一半人还没到投票年龄。福布斯竞选团队声称拥有新罕布什尔州最大的共和党青年组织。当你参加竞选活动时，这个说法似乎是可信的。那里总是有更多的年轻人支持福布斯，当你想到这一点时，这令人难以置信。史蒂夫·福布斯，那个主张单一税的候选人？我的意思是，还有什么问题比美国税法更难激励全国青少年的吗？大多数青少年甚至都没见过1040税表。
It's going to be a mail-in postcard. That's going to be great. That's going to be so much easier than anything else, especially reading through all the laws and then filling out a 10-page report.
那将是一张邮寄明信片。那太棒了。那将比任何其他方式都简单得多，尤其是不用阅读所有法律然后填写一份10页的报告。
Aside from their views on taxes, most of what the Forbes kids say isn't what you'd typically call conservative. When I do pin them down on what issues they care about, they trot out these suspiciously liberal chestnuts-- global warming and education. I ask how Forbes' plan to radically scale back the size of government will help address these issues. An athletic type named John tells me it's simply a matter of resource allocation.
除了他们对税收的看法外，福布斯孩子们说的大部分内容通常不被称之为保守派。当我真的追问他们关心什么问题时，他们抛出了这些令人怀疑的自由派陈词滥调——全球变暖和教育。我问福布斯大幅削减政府规模的计划将如何帮助解决这些问题。一个名叫约翰的运动型学生告诉我，这仅仅是资源分配的问题。
For example, in Manchester a lot of money the past couple years has been spent in law enforcement trying to take skateboarding off of the streets.
例如，在曼彻斯特，过去几年里，大量资金被花费在执法上，试图将滑板从街道上赶走。
We all skateboard, by the way.
顺便说一句，我们都玩滑板。
Not to be biased or anything. But a lot of wasted money was used to hire more cops to just go downtown and bust people for having a fun time. That money could have been spent on education.
不是说有偏见。但很多浪费的钱被用来雇佣更多的警察，只是去市中心抓那些玩得开心的人。那些钱本可以花在教育上。
During John's little speech, all the kids were crowding around and making these funny little hand gestures. It went like this. Hold your hand with your fingers extended in a karate chop position. Then fold the bottom two fingers back into your palm. The kids held both hands in this position, two fingers extended, and sort of chopped them up and down as John talked. Fifteen or 20 of them, all doing it at once.
在约翰的小演讲中，所有的孩子都围过来，做着这些滑稽的手势。它是这样的。保持手掌伸展，手指呈空手道劈砍位置。然后将底部两个手指折回手掌中。孩子们双手都保持这个位置，两根手指伸出，随着约翰的讲话上下摆动。十五或二十个孩子，同时做着这个动作。
I asked one of them about it. Oh, that's just what Steve does when he talks, Mike says. It's very French, Ryan explains. And then Ted demonstrates how the gesture fits into a timeline of presidential hand postures. He makes a fist, his thumb on top.
我问其中一个孩子关于这件事。哦，那是史蒂夫说话时的样子，迈克说。这很“法式”，瑞安解释道。然后泰德演示了这个姿势如何适合总统手势的时间线。他握成拳头，拇指在上面。
JFK did this with the thumb. See my thumb is at my index. He went do-do-do-do-do.
肯尼迪（JFK）就是这样用拇指的。看我的拇指在食指上。他这样做道道道道。
He tucks the thumb into the fist.
他把拇指塞进拳头里。
And then Bill Clinton, his thumb inside, like this. And Steve Forbes is just an open hand like this.
然后比尔·克林顿，拇指在里面，像这样。而史蒂夫·福布斯只是张开手，像这样。
The two fingers, and you can tell--
两个手指，你可以看出——
They say you can tell how excited he is by how high in the air his hands get.
他们说你可以看出他有多兴奋，通过他的手在空中举得有多高。
I've only seen up like eyebrow level. Some people have seen overhead, though.
我只见过举到眉毛水平。不过有些人见过举过头顶。
Oh, I've seen overhead a few times, actually. I've seen an overhead when we bring a lot of people to the rallies, he sees us, he jumps into the speech about Social Security, just like he said. He jumps up there. He's very into it.
哦，其实我见过几次过头顶的情况。我见过我们在集会上带很多人去时，他看到我们，他就像他说的那样跳到关于社会保障的演讲中。他跳起来。他非常投入。
Time to go to work. He's coming in.
该工作了。他来了。
If you don't have orange, put orange on please. If you don't have orange, put orange on please.
如果你没有橙色，请穿上橙色。如果你没有橙色，请穿上橙色。
At the far side of the room, the presidential debate on television ended. And at a certain point, the call came that Forbes was on his way.
在房间的另一端，电视上的总统辩论结束了。在某个时候，传来了福布斯正在赶来的消息。
I mean, millions of people are watching this at home. And they're going to go home tomorrow, go to school tomorrow and say, yeah, I watched it on TV. Well, we didn't watch it. We made it happen.
我的意思是，数百万人正在家里看这个。他们明天会回家，明天去学校说，是的，我在电视上看到了。嗯，我们没有看。我们创造了它。
We made it happen.
我们创造了它。
This is just great.
这太棒了。
We were there.
我们在那里。
We were. We were here.
我们在。我们在这里。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
You said you want him. Now you've got him.
你说你想要他。现在你得到了他。
Forbes finally arrives. And the kids' impersonations of his oratorical style are remarkably accurate. His hands karate chop up and down on every syllable. He looks like a badly operated puppet.
福布斯终于到达了。孩子们对他的演讲风格的模仿非常准确。他的手在每一个音节上都像空手道劈砍一样上下摆动。他看起来像一个被笨拙操作的木偶。
With your help, we can make it happen. And  before I go, I do want to introduce you again-- most of you have met her-- to the one who is going to make a superb First Lady. She's raised five daughters. And if you can do that, you can handle the politicians of Washington. My wife, Sabina.
在你们的帮助下，我们可以实现它。在我走之前，我确实想再次介绍——你们大多数人已经见过她了——那位将成为出色第一夫人的人。她抚养了五个女儿。如果能做到这一点，你就能处理华盛顿的政客们。我的妻子，萨比娜。
At this, kids spontaneously burst into Wayne and Garth we're not worthy bows in the direction of Forbes' wife. She beams at them. They beam back. They've gone through this ritual before. On his way out, after finishing a speech, Forbes walked up to some of the kids, including Ryan and Chris, and shook their hands.
听到这话，孩子们自发地向福布斯的妻子做出了《韦恩的世界》中“我们不配”的鞠躬。她对他们微笑。他们也对她微笑。他们以前经历过这种仪式。在他演讲结束准备离开时，福布斯走到一些孩子身边，包括瑞安和克里斯，并与他们握手。
He shook your hand?
他跟你握手了？
Yes, he shook my hand.
是的，他跟我握手了。
Did he say anything to you?
他跟你说了什么吗？
He said, thank you for the support.
他说，谢谢你们的支持。
Compare to this to another way you felt at other times in your life.
把你生命中其他时刻的感觉与此比较一下。
It feels like the first time I landed a Misty Flip.
感觉就像我第一次完成“Misty Flip”一样。
Misty Flip, a snowboarding maneuver in which the rider turns a forward sommersault, while at the same time, rotating his body axially. Let's continue.
Misty Flip，一种单板滑雪动作，骑手做一个前空翻，同时身体轴向旋转。我们继续。
I'm sorry, to take your time. Mr. Forbes, I was just at the event tonight.
对不起，耽误你的时间了。福布斯先生，我刚才就在今晚的活动现场。
When I catch up with the candidate himself, he's clearly pleased with his newfound popularity among the cool kids, even if he doesn't completely understand it.
当我赶上候选人本人时，他显然对他这种在酷小孩中新发现的欢迎度感到高兴，即使他并不完全理解它。
Do you know what a Misty Flip is?
你知道什么是“Misty Flip”吗？
Well, I like vanilla stuff, and the Misty Flip--
嗯，我喜欢香草味的东西，而“Misty Flip”——
No, no. Wrong. Wrong.
不，不。错了。错了。
--is chocolate.
——是巧克力味的。
He goes on to tell me that his campaign is an idealistic one, and that's part of the appeal to teenagers. But it still doesn't explain the essential question. How did this stiff, socially awkward man corral the passions of New Hampshire's skate punks? Well, meet 21-year-old Mike DelBene.
他接着告诉我，他的竞选活动是一个理想主义的竞选，这对青少年有一定的吸引力。但它仍然不能解释最基本的问题。这个死板、社交尴尬的男人是如何聚集起新罕布什尔州滑板朋克的热情的？好吧，认识一下21岁的迈克·德尔本（Mike DelBene）。
I get that question a lot. I get a lot of, well, how do you get kids out to support a candidate who may not be real smooth or may not be real funny? I wish I could say that all I had to do was wave a picture of Steve Forbes in front of their face and they would come running. You can't do that.
这个问题我经常被问到。我经常被问到，好吧，你是如何让孩子们出来支持一个可能不圆滑、可能不风趣的候选人的？我希望我能说我所要做的只是在他们面前挥舞一张史蒂夫·福布斯的照片，他们就会跑过来。你不能那样做。
Mike DelBene is a regional youth coordinator for Forbes 2000. He's also the reason all these teenagers love Steve Forbes. How does he do it? One of his main recruiting tricks is simply being Mike DelBene. Chelsea White, one of Mike's recruits, says that when Mike came to her school, he was somehow different than the competition.
迈克·德尔本是“福布斯2000”的区域青年协调员。他也是所有这些青少年热爱史蒂夫·福布斯的原因。他是怎么做到的？他的主要招募秘诀之一仅仅就是因为他是迈克·德尔本。切尔西·怀特（Chelsea White），迈克招募的人之一，说当迈克来到她的学校时，他与竞争对手以某种方式不同。
The guy that came for Bush, he was just boring. He had no idea what he was talking about. He had nothing to say. He just talked about himself, and he didn't really say, oh, we get to do this and we get to do that. He just said, vote for Bush, vote for Bush. And we were just like, OK, nope.
那个为布什而来的人，他简直无聊透顶。他根本不知道自己在说什么。他什么也没说。他只是谈论他自己，他并没有真正说，哦，我们能做这个，我们能做那个。他只是说，投票给布什，投票给布什。我们就觉得，好吧，不行。
So what exactly did Mike say, I ask her, that made volunteering sound so fun, so appealing, that she signed up with Forbes?
所以我问她，迈克到底说了什么，让志愿者工作听起来如此有趣、如此吸引人，以至于她报名参加了福布斯？
He was just telling us about all the campaigns, and the debates, and lit drops and what everybody does and stuff.
他只是告诉我们所有的竞选活动、辩论、发传单以及每个人都在做什么等等。
OK. Lit drops?
好吧。发传单？
What I always try to do is I always try to take everything that we do and put a fun twist on it. Not only when we actually do it, but when I explain it. Like a literature drop, you take a literature drop that adults are doing. They'll walk up with a piece of literature to a door, they'll knock on the door, the person will come out, they'll introduce themselves, they'll explain, they'll say, this is the literature for Steve Forbes. We would like you to come vote. And they'll take hours and hours to do it. Youth for Forbes, we take literature, we hang it on the door knob, we knock, ring the doorbell, and run away.
我总是尝试做的是，我总是尝试把我们所做的一切都赋予有趣的转折。不仅是在我们实际做的时候，而且是在我解释它的时候。比如发传单，你看看成年人是如何分发传单的。他们会带着传单走向门口，敲门，那人出来，他们介绍自己，他们解释，他们说，这是史蒂夫·福布斯的传单。我们希望你来投票。他们会花几个小时来做。而“福布斯青年团”，我们拿上传单，挂在门把手上，敲门，按门铃，然后跑开。
Ringing and running for Forbes.
为福布斯按门铃然后逃跑。
Ringing and running for Forbes is exactly what it is. Absolutely. And we have a great time doing it. We have a great time doing it. Yeah. I ask them to just come try it, to just come try it once. And they come out, they can feel the excitement of the campaign, the excitement of the lights, the cameras. And I always give them the opportunity to meet the candidate.
为福布斯按门铃然后逃跑，完全就是这么回事。当然。我们做这些非常开心。我们做这些非常开心。是的。我邀请他们过来试一次，仅仅试一次。他们出来后，他们能感受到竞选活动的兴奋感、灯光、摄像机。我总是给他们机会去见候选人。
I think if you take a kid who says, I don't care about politics. What do I care, you know? And you put him in a room with a presidential candidate, and the presidential candidate walks over and stops and looks him right in the eye, says hello, and shakes his hand, as tough as that kid tries to be tough and say, ah, that didn't make me-- his eyes are going to light up. All the hair on the back of his neck's going to stand up, and he's going to go away feeling tickled pink. Because young people need and want and appreciate being part of something huge like this. They want to be part of what's going on.
我认为如果你带一个说“我不在乎政治，我能关心什么？”的孩子，你把他放在一个有总统候选人的房间里，总统候选人走过来，停下来，直视他的眼睛，问候他，并握他的手，无论那个孩子试图表现得多么强硬，试图说“啊，那没让我怎样”——他的眼睛会发光。他后颈上的所有汗毛都会竖起来，他会感到非常激动。因为年轻人需要、想要并珍惜成为像这样巨大事件的一部分。他们想要成为正在发生的事情的一部分。
And then once they're hooked to being part of what's going on, now they sit down and they listen to Steve. And now they hear what he's saying. Students actually believe in a flat tax, the students that work with us. They actually believe that Social Security should be privatized. They actually are pro-life. But what gets them out is the excitement.
一旦他们被吸引成为正在发生的事情的一部分，现在他们坐下来，听史蒂夫说话。现在他们听到了他在说什么。学生们实际上相信单一税，那些与我们一起工作的学生。他们实际上相信社会保障应该私有化。他们实际上是反堕胎的。但让他们走出来的动力是那种兴奋感。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
[听不清]
Here, this is what Mike DelBene has wrought. At an all-ages punk show at the Sad Cafe in Plaistow, New Hampshire, there are high school seniors who can quote Steve Forbes' best lines in Steve Forbes' voice like their favorite song lyrics. And 17-year-old Ryan tells me this.
在这里，这就是迈克·德尔本所造成的。在位于新罕布什尔州普莱斯托 Sad Cafe 的一场全年龄朋克演出中，有高中三年级的学生能像唱最喜欢的歌曲歌词一样，以史蒂夫·福布斯的声音引用史蒂夫·福布斯的最佳台词。17岁的瑞安告诉我这一点。
I'm at the office almost every day just recruiting and making phone calls and doing any other job that they need. I've found something that I actually want to do for the rest of my life-- politics.
我几乎每天都在办公室招募人员、打电话，做他们需要的任何其他工作。我发现了一些我实际上想做一辈子的事情——政治。
Say hypothetically Forbes doesn't get the nomination this go-around. All the hours, all the volunteers, all the cold calls, what does it accomplish to run for president and lose? What does a failed presidential bid create in the world? It's entirely possible that the most lasting achievement of the Forbes campaign will be how it affects the lives of these teenagers, true believers in the flat tax, true believers in the political process. As New Hampshire's finest punk rock blasts through the club's speakers, I watch the kids, future campaign managers, press secretaries, political strategists, fling themselves around the mosh pit like spawning salmon.
假设如果福布斯这次没有获得提名。所有的工作时间，所有的志愿者，所有的冷电话，竞选总统并失败有什么意义？失败的总统竞选会在世界上创造什么？完全有可能福布斯竞选活动最持久的成就将是它如何影响这些青少年的生活，这些单一税的真正信仰者，政治过程的真正信仰者。当新罕布什尔州最棒的朋克摇滚通过俱乐部的扬声器爆炸时，我看着这些孩子，未来的竞选经理、新闻秘书、政治策略师，像产卵的鲑鱼一样在人潮中来回穿梭。
Alex Blumberg.
亚历克斯·布隆伯格。
Well, our program was produced today by Alex Blumberg and myself, with Susan Burton, Blue Chevigny, and Julie Snyder. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, Alix Spiegel, Nancy Updike, and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Todd Bachman and Starlee Kine, our producer trainee. This is her last program with us. We will badly, badly miss her.
好吧，我们今天的节目是由亚历克斯·布隆伯格和我本人制作的，还有苏珊·伯顿、布鲁·切维尼和朱莉·斯奈德。特约编辑保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、南希·厄普代克，以及顾问萨拉·沃威尔。制作帮助来自我们的实习制片人托德·巴赫曼和斯塔莉·凯恩。这是她与我们在一起的最后一个节目。我们将非常非常想念她。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
To buy a cassette of this program, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. But you know, you can listen to most of our programs for free on the internet at our website www.thisamericanlife.org This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
要购买本节目的磁带，请致电芝加哥的WBEZ，电话312-832-3380。但你知道，你可以在我们的网站 www.thisamericanlife.org 上免费收听我们的大部分节目。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台分发。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who told us this at our last staff meeting--
WBEZ管理监督托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia），他在我们上次员工会议上这样告诉我们——
I found a little place in upstate New York called Love Canal.
我在纽约北部发现了一个叫拉夫运河的小地方。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with most stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着《美国生活》的更多故事回来。
That was the one that started it all.
那是开启了一切的那一个。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。